good morning Hank it's Tuesday so we
need to talk about your last Blood
Brothers video and not the one with a
Gregory Brothers song a fight our fight
about Batman the one before that where
you talked about I actually don't
remember what you talked about because I
was too focused on this so mike
nerdfighter reviews of your new haircut
we're universally positive but then
again
nerdfighteria is a very supportive and
loving community whereas I am your
brother Hank in my life I've had three
major hairstyles for about the past 15
years I've had some variation of short
on the sides messy up top before that
for many years I had a haircut called
the junior senator from Maryland and
then of course there was my original
haircut toad from Mario Cart meanwhile
have your entire life you've had just
the one hairstyle which I call the Hank
I can't even describe the exact
properties of the Hank to you because it
just is it's like trying to describe
water to a fish the Hank is that which
sits atop Hanks head and then suddenly
change unannounced radical change now
hey cuz you know I'm not a huge fan of
change
I just think change is tremendously
overrated people are always like life is
change and that's true but you know what
else has changed death but Hank your
hairstyle change upset me particularly
because it reminded me a little bit of
Kennedy's haircut you know the left back
of the AFC wimbledon wimbly wand lee's
the fictional soccer team might play
fifa 14 with i think i realized that
when it comes to hair i live in the
glass east of glass houses but i've been
throwing rocks at kennedy's hair for
years now and then suddenly my own
brother adopts a version of the kennedy
well Hank this led to a bit of an
existential crisis I admittedly these
days it doesn't take much to point me in
the direction of an existential crisis
but I started thinking about my brother
who is a real person in real life I
really like and then there's Kennedy a
very talented but fictional left-back
who's technically made out of pixels but
now in my head they're connected so
anything I say about Kennedy's hair I'm
sort of implying about your hair Hank
and all they just made me think about
how nothing that happens in one
so-called virtual life can ever be like
fully disconnected from what happens in
your so-called real life right I think
realness might be more of like a
continuum than an actual thing you know
like ultimately selfhood and
relationships and experiences and FIFA
playing and whatever else are varying
degrees of real rather than simply real
or not like I get my life there are two
AFC Wimbledon's right there the AFC one
Winley Wang Lee's a fictional FIFA team
who have worked their way up from Ligue
2 and are now enjoying their first
season in the Premier League and it's
going great because ball John Green and
other John green are two strikers have
found renewed form since the adoption of
their baby boy JJ and that will Wimbley
wombly world is to quote severus snape
real for us us being the weird and
lovely people who support the wind we
want lace and then we use the ad revenue
from that series to sponsor the other
AFC Wimbledon the you know the real one
that AFC Wimbledon is an actual
professional soccer team in England but
it started 13 years ago from nothing
except a bunch of fans who had the idea
to make a soccer team the fact that
imagination and work can make ideas
reals would finally resolve this
existential crisis because it's like the
most beautiful and lovely thing about
life to me the whole thing just maybe
want to support AFC Wimbledon more if we
can so I'm gonna try to do more video
gaming stuff I've started a twitch TV
channel and even though I don't really
know how it works I'm gonna try
broadcasting today there's a link in the
doobly-doo so basically Hank your new
haircut made me think about what's real
and what's not real and how much I
admire people like you and the founders
of AFC Wimbledon for working so hard to
make awesome things real and then I was
like you know what I kind of like Hanks
new haircut which by extension means
that I guess now I kind of like
Kennedy's haircut and FIFA this was a
very weird vlogbrothers video I will see
you on Friday